[Musik]
sig ja immer alle ich s so sicher in der
Entscheid und zeig sogar das südlich das
Z WM los da ist dumszüg ich habe immer
an jedem Entscheid
zwifel vor allem noch meistens merke ich
da ich ma ma ich das und fertig es
geht's nicht Andes und dann
kommt nch denken hinterher denken und
dann wird's nicht schön das ist W V
intuitive Menschen die plaget das
nachher immer da das Mus ST und die
Einsamkeit um hät die der füg die m K
noch
träge
[Musik]
[Applaus]
grüte
mitinand
da G
gut
ja ich hat sitz ich zu dir ja gut nimm
das Christoph Blocher referiert vor
begeisterten Anhängern über die Schweiz
und die EU sein
Lieblingsthema so
schönü
ja
le ja ja ja
ja do h dann da hinf stroffe da
[Musik]
danke mal wen ich Möglichkeit
hat
[Musik]
20 genoss
genoss Gebiet wenn wir selber bestimmen
ob mir bestimmen ein ander da gibt's nur
ein Wort Widerstand wen schon mal so
eine
Situation schwi führen die wichtigste
abstimm im letzten Jahrhundert über den
Europäischen
Wirtschaftsraum das so
harmlos das ist noch nicht der D gesagt
ist Trainingslager D die also bevor
Paradies muss noch nicht trainieren oder
[Applaus]
was ist passiert die ganze klasspitik
der Bundesrat fast ganz Parlament
kantonsregier praktisch sämtliche Z in
der
Schwiz m dir verre das nicht mach sch
wenn Journalist
die blöd
fürn schwizerolk mein Kraft s nein
Widerstand mir blieb
[Applaus]
selbständig die
Frau BL über
[Applaus]
ichand
die
Kraft
Frau ja das kein blöds verzählen oder
fahüber
oder nach andere Frau aufgestanden
also sie gagt das ist typisch für sie
wie St natürlich Frau hinterin und vin
ich gesagt wenn sie wäand aber
[Applaus]
wä ja da ist
wichtig bitte bitte sie se
gro
[Musik]
seit2 der Schweiz und verhindert so die
enge Anbindung an die
[Musik]
EU
BL wir treffen ihn mehrmals für
ausführliche
Interviews er führt uns zuerst in seine
Kunstsammlung vor allem der bernermaler
Albert Anker fasziniert
ihn so das ich also vorübergen dieoen
ist da sind Bilder wo Duell gegangen
sind z sind und noch nicht Ort und stell
sind aber was da an der Wand hanget das
ist alles Albert
aner
vielleicht fangen wir z mal
anen also da sind jetzt da aber da da
hinter da seh sie eigentlich Hauptwerk
vom aner und da sind jetzt denan na
besonders
schön ist der schulspaziergang S über 20
Jahr hab ich das Bild be V noch nie
ausgewachselt das ist jedes Tag
faszinierend keis von de Kind ragt über
der
horizontus aber ein Person RT über der
horizontus in Himmel das ist
lehrere wenn sie mit der Z l merk sie V
da bis zu Demin
und da bis zu der hinterste schitel ist
es W Dach
die unter Dach von der LEH natürlich ist
ein
Mensch das
git n der Mensch das für euch Religion
religios ich muss aufpassen
religiös wor aber ich glaube und ich bin
überzugt dass hö
machtt und auch ich finde und
das wier
l mE nicht verdammt wir steh alle unter
der vorsä und der gnad Gottes wen wir
gar nicht wären wir nicht da nicht und
könnte da nicht alles wo wir machen ist
im Grund no und für alle Menschen für
Gegner aber doch einigesreicht im Le ja
getroffen das ja nicht a Zufall g es
sind mir ge Sachen gerade ich sag immer
so s gerade weil hätte
abfreck aufpassen wenn man gemacht h und
gut
und das weiß ich auch got ich bin ein
intuitiver Mensch ich einfach entschied
ich mach also selbst wenn der Mensch se
ich gemacht ich gemacht ein H ist Hal
[Musik]
okay zweiter Bundesrat sit gefordert
vorgeschlagen auf der Front NZZ jawoh ja
der G langerh vorbereitet g dem ja das
ist ein gut Strategie wir sind ja
verpflichtet Strategie jetzt machen ich
habe gest mit von der SVP ketei auf der
tischleit was man jetzt
machtt ist
mit1tim Herr Nationalrat
[Applaus]
Christop ich mache was ich kann und ich
hoffe dass uns Gott helfe dass es gut
[Applaus]
[Musik]
rauskommt ich schwöre
es
felicitation alles gut so gut
gratuliere der neugewählte Bundesrat
verkauft sein Unternehmen an seine
Kinder Mitarbeiterinen und Mitarbeiter
nur no paar Tag kann ich so
sieen am 3 Dezember mus Schluss machen
das L jeden Tag in den Z dan ich kan
nicht
trinen also sind Sie
willkommen schön
oder oder daszäh sie denn was sie da
jetzt
schon
jetzt ja ja gut D
sch und und V
wichtig arbeitsgät und drum
ich was für Bedürfnis hat und dann hab
was
was wirklich recht
schön Sitzgruppe
hab
sieerus im bundesus antik und gebraucht
aber sehr
schön
[Musik]
kaffell morgen
frü
und den sch
[Musik]
Papier und
warum freut ja das gegil natürlich V
Papier oder
aber Symbol vom Z aber ja es gibt Hal ge
Sachen die m bra Axt und die wo im meine
Axt ausklammer und die Kraft auskam die
H fürs GLE das gehört da zum le sie die
Kraft und tax da still
vetes und wer nur sein von demm Vertrag
[Musik]
gestt Christoph Blocher provoziert auch
als Bundesrat für böses Blut gesorgt hat
er bereits im Vorfeld der gestrigen
Abstimmungen als er sichtbar lustlos die
einbürgerungsvorlagen des Bundesrates in
der Öffentlichkeit
präsentierte
[Gelächter]
auf
ren für die
vorlesrat
und
gen die Vorlage kämpft SVP
Präsident S ist integriert andere
Kulturreise der familiet aber es
n jetzt bin ich im Bundesrat und es ist
verpflichtig vor der bundesrät deine
vorlag wo der Bundesrat Schloss hat
sogar die wo früherchloss hat n
bekämpfen ja natürlich Pflicht ist
pflichtin ist das
so zerrissen wie da in der Arena hat man
sie mal gesehen und ich denke das könen
Sie doch nicht la machen ich das sindort
für mich oder doch viel müss V Volk TR
und Züg vertr gegen m in überzügig also
ein Politiker wo wo Meinig und richtig
den vol
Diesl dem Jahr 2004 an der Urne für die
Befürworter ist klar dass der
persönliche Einsatz auch derjenige eines
Bundesrates durchaus ausschlaggebend
sein kann für das Resultat
einerstim der nächste Konflikt die
bilateralen 2 mit dem sogenannten
Schengenabkommen der gesamte Bundesrat
setzt sich unter der Führung des
Bundespräsidenten für die bilateralen
zwe ein wenn ich sage geschlossen der
ist das Definition vom
Kollegialitätsprinzip die Abstimmung im
Bundesrat zum Schengen Beitritt war
weder einstimmig noch steht der
Bundesrat heute geschlossen hinter
diesem Projekt alles andere ist
wahrheitswidrig also ich habe noch
vollofnung für seine intellektuelle
Entwicklung was Schengen
betrifft Herr gusch hat ein seh
relitäres Demokratieverständnis nach dem
Flugzeugabsturz Überlingen mit über 40
Toten Kindern sagt Blocher zu
Verkehrsminister Leuenberger ich an
deiner Stelle würde
zurücktreten Bundesrat leuberg zum
Rücktritt aufforder
V
kompet wir haben die Problematik der
Indiskretionen schon mehrmals diskutiert
ich natürlich aus der Wirtschaft für eus
ist der Konflikt
der Entscheid findig normal mir fleget
das sogar und das ist im Bundesrat nicht
nicht ich g und ich hab immer Abstimmung
verlangt ke stell das S Zimmer gefunden
machen wir doch nicht oder wir noch seit
der Bundesrat hab beschlossen und
nach gesag wen gesag se
meh
sie merken ja die politisch Landschaft
bricht auf will wenn
sie FL
odercht wie was ja
nein gutfang für das es g nicht so
wier
sorgt für
werbel also der fotog
wünscht ST so schlecht und Schwiz was
müsst sich er im hütigge System sie
michade
direkt ja ich habe natürlich sehr viel
schwi le
regier nicht so tatkräftig Sie wie Sie
könte sie wenn sie wenn sie irgendwie
homogener wärlich Mehrheit zum
bürgerlich könte ja könnte ja anderes
auchfassen CVP die Grünen und dann danke
ich Hal das würde ich sehr viel
schlagkräftig und ich meine mir hätte
nötig in der
[Musik]
Schwiz
und hab sie das gesagt und dann ist das
Aufgen worden und dann hat ziemlich Grum
und dann ist wieder Spiel und so dass
sie sag es lauft nach tre ja ist klar
vor allem sind ich im bundesr diskutiere
mir natürlich viel über die Frage und
das sie lanciiert ohne dass das ein Z W
aber die
grundsatzf wieder im drebur inen
[Musik]
oder keine zwei Menschen wo so nch
zammen sind wie mir jetzt in Umkreis
also ich hab niemand so eng
gesprchpartner be meine Frau oder das
ist schon einüsserlich oder also wir
leben Z wir wohnen wir essen wir
schlafen zmen wir der freizit sind wir
zammen und meine Frau ist sehr gut
gesprchspartner erstens sie ist
geschieht oder das ist natürlich wichtig
sie ist sehr emotional das nicht so
einfach und drittens sie
nimmt sehr Teil den Problem wo man h und
das ist natürlich wertvoll will ma ja
vieles gar nicht besprechen an sich mit
und viele immer gesagt werag könen
machen wenn die Frau nicht seid ja das
weiß ich nicht sicher aber mit der Frau
nicht teil und wo das gegenteilemt W
sicherlich Gang ich bin natürlich
überzeugt dass mir außerordentliche
Fähigkeit hat das muss ich schon sagen
er hat sehr
schnellassgab ich GewSt das komt gut der
wird sehr schnell wissen um was es geht
wird und sehr entscheidigfreudig oder
also nicht nur sonder hat nachher
auchentscheidungsfreudig
[Gelächter]
undentlich rskarriere bald vorbei sein
wird und das hängt mit seinem politstil
[Musik]
zusammen Rückblende in die 90er Jahre
Christoph Blocher damals Nationalrat
verspottet seine politischen Gegner
regelmäßig hat M gest tetten am Fernseh
der Arena da mit Meer Freundin der Frau
Koch wie der Industrie wie der
Produktion wie der und Mittelbetrieb
dann ruiniert man da D mit Produktion
und das macht sie massiv und
sie
ja sie sind einfach im Flegel ich
muss
bra eigentlich ein aber ich bin schön
ruhig also ich find das
unglau unglaublich wie sie
sich
ich Freund dielich immer von
[Applaus]
[Musik]
mir Lauf nicht mir aber bra politische
Linie
g sie fü sch sie führ sch nein nicht
mein ich denke wenn das kann
ich ja wir jetzt blau gemacht undürt
damit
Angst Stiefel
Derin dass dir sicher also der sicher
nicht übrigens noch
nie
kstt
ich unglaublich das
sefelinserat das ist schon in der ganze
Schwiz verbreitet bevor wir einmal Dru
über all die Jahre provoziert Blochers
SVP immer wieder mit umstrittenen
Kampagnen das
plakato miremach H
zasinitiative WS Sie warum dass die alle
das
will stimmt will stimmt da kriminelle
Schwizer fah dur das ist zeiget
wunderschön sie ja nicht meine die Plage
Stil der Plag
[Musik]
Wort sie
Haltis ze das komm oder
alles in zit und das ma ich ja nicht so
bewusst oder aber in ein Kampfsituation
K
sieerich
schüß Plakate über Ausländer lösen
heftige Diskussionen
[Musik]
aus begonnen hat der aggressive
politstiltil
1993 mit dem sogenannten
stecherinelat dass da GÜ verletzt sind
und troffen sind dur das inrat das ich
will natürlich sehr viel liglich merke
dass sie Mitschuld sind der verfält
entwickl die Fam von der N und der linke
sie sie zuständig und verantwortlich für
dieich zunehmende die Kriminalität ich
dasratischisch aber mit der für der
Hintergrund nicht vergessen das ist
Anfang von Kampagne wo wir der Schwiz
nicht gewet sind das Politkultur wir die
Schwiz nicht kennach schwarzwiesmaleri a
FB a Ausgrenze ihr s sch ich GLB ist
tatsächlich so dass man h mit einfach
Mittel muss sagen sie beleidiget ein
politische Gegner damit und wer Hass
seid der wird sturmte und dem
entsprechend könen wir die direkte
Demokratie nicht soand los ich
schockiert und erschüttert wenn man sich
in der jugendzit erinnert was im Usland
passiert ist unter dem Titel vor der
tostoßlegende wo man zerst die
L mit Vorwurf über Hüft se denn
geistiggrenzt und dass man physisch
vernichtet h und am
Schluss der ganze spuckag das haben wir
nicht gewollt nicht und V Mirus geseh
muss man
stigewand und
stige Methode vfang Paro sag so geht es
nicht
in jetzt im Nachhinein das Messerstecher
die politische Kampagne wie das
bestemacht Best let sie sind die
freisinnige W sie gesag ja mit der n s
mir gemeint was nichtm stimmt aber se
sicher auf freisinig nicht sind aber
sogarich warum das das das das ist meine
Überzeugung und ich kann s ihen auch
auch auch Dargen das tönt wunderbar aber
genauso totalitär sind sie
innenpolitisch wenn Sie die netten und
die Linken der
das Gen das ist die gleiche mentalit so
kommen wir nicht
weit über die Linken und die netten was
haben wir gesagt bitte nicht bitte
nicht in letzte 100
Jahre wieder mal zeigen wir sten zu dem
Land wir sind dafür Flagen zeigen und
die m sie nicht zeigen Wiese was kein
Mensch hat Bahnhofstraße abich die sind
da die das gibt große lärme schiebe von
de Großbank s noch zu mer
[Musik]
s der triler Aufmarsch in der
Bahnhofstraße von
[Applaus]
[Musik]
Zürich
warumü das selbverständlich zum der
bewegig unterstütze wo ich glaube in der
ganze Schwiz jetzt langsam und immer
noch stärker
[Applaus]
wird Lochers Demonstration provoziert es
kommt auf der anderen Seite der lemat zu
Gegendemonstration zwischen links und
rechtsextremen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
wir wen
ke
wirtisch
Andersdenkende zu grenzen lächerlich zu
machen als heimatmüde zu bezeichnen darf
nicht zum Stil der politischen
Auseinandersetzung in der Schweiz werden
genauso wenig wie
Gewalt polarisierende Polit schwitz
vorher noch
nicht ja ich find gar nicht schlimm wenn
eine polarisiert was hei das eigentlich
es vertritt ein starke Meinig und wenn
er dir vertritt den gibt's ander der
vertritt Gegenteil auch fest dann gibt's
zwei Pol wo ich in der Schwiz bin ich
aufgefallen mit der
hauppolarisierung das ist B der W von
der Unabhängigkeit von der Schwiz und da
sie nicht
klar und das polarisiert W die ganz
glaspitik das passiert ist richtig
Europäische Union marschiert
Unabhängigkeit
bra was der Vorteil ist dass wir no
selber
[Musik]
bestimmen dem Stier aggressiv Bewandnis
mit
Fr das pas gut zu
mireh aggressiv aus ja nein ja nein ja
aggressiv kraftusdruck V Kraft und
leibenswien
und
[Musik]
jaön
oder laufen im Kanton Zürich in der Nähe
des Rheinfalls hier kommt Christoph
Blocher 1940 auf die
Welt
VAT
11 das zei genur aber
[Musik]
nieung 11 Kinder Tisch und Vater m geh
also wenn der Vater Regel g man nicht
R sich
und wir DF unterinand schwitz ich den
erste Jahr im groß kinderslaufzimmer
gaufen jetzt sind die sie jüngste
übernacht miteinand ist natürlich
ziemlich
bewegt früh ins Bett am 7 mit Mutter
hätte der Hus gemacht geseh morgen 6 ich
meistens erst gen Mitternacht ist Beck
sie gesagt am s Bett
bet Mutter jeden ab der größte
anstrengig ist stür
und
kurz Gott dank dir für alles du
geschenkt h dann ist uns Vater und dann
gibt gute Nacht Vater der Mutter dann
man alle Kind
ABN
Martin also es ist lustig Z gegangen und
dann ist Mutter gegangen und wenn sie
gegangen ist wieder stillgestanden
zuinand bis wir wieder gehört do und ste
der wieder
verschwunden der Lauf nur bestand aus
pfarhus der Chill ein klein purhof das
ist der Messmer und größer purhof und
schloss und so sind na g und ich bin
wenn immer möglich diei mich V Tür
gestellt zum Nachbar da dirka da
roskaü da ein bur der H
mit auf Feld und das H mir sehr passt
und bin mal in
Land in Kanton Bern auf K wi Bern und da
ich ich bur ich w
Burg und der Vater hat mir
abgeroten er hat nicht unrechtke gesagt
du hast kein querb du ich gesagt ja D
muss ich Hal Pächter werden oder sch bur
Nacht hat gesagt mach mit W einfach
schwierig dann hat ich ein bur Lehr
gemacht später holt er die Matura nach
und studiert
[Musik]
recht
ideal R k r Bescheide aber das hab wir
nicht gemerkt oder
empfunden und heute ist der mehrfacher
Milliardär so könen wir da Museum das
ist Bü
Museum meine Frau schöne Kunst gemacht
ist wunderbares Kunstmuseum worden da
sie da da sind sie da in
chtis
Metis da auf die se s sie da Albert t
Dach sie mal die Farbe prach das ist der
die Farbe bracht doch unglaublich schön
die Konstellation
und die Sch V Mensch als
solches
künstis und war TR
zumung Arbeiter s ganz dü Löcher
das
idealisiert viel Arbeit l aber ich
Bilder wo großer Armseligkeit und in
düchterkeit auf wird aber trotzdem
zeiget D das Welt trotzdem nicht
verloren
[Musik]
ist
verherrlich ja ja das merk das packt
doch richtig wie schön dass das ist das
kindft
Gatz der
armselige Welt vor
demürzte Hus was der Mensch brauch das
ist Geborgenheit und das findet
Geborgenheit auf dem Bank und wer
daset der PL
inut sondern der ist begeistert von der
geborge von dem
Kind wenn
Vater Armut und wenn jetzt z.B Afrika
der ja l verarmt drum flüchte sie das ja
Wirtschaftsflüchtlinge drum flüte sie
nach Europa furchtbare LED die Überfahrt
viel
sterben die kein hoffn mehr drum sie
hoff S bben und schaffen die wo wirklich
Liebe und Leben bedroht sind das ke Hof
me die m ne und die ne haben wir ein sch
sehr hoch gesetzt es DF nicht
interessant sie nicht schaffen al die
schaffe man muss nicht meine der Mensch
wo n hat oder armis es ist richtig wenn
man der nimmt und den da versorgt da ist
der chines realistischer der SEAG immer
wenn ein Hunger hat gib nicht gib nicht
de Fisch gib Fischer
R
[Musik]
so
schön
ja also es geht zwei Versionen eine von
meiner Frau und eine von ich
ich der keine g li undfunden se
wunderschöne Frau und hatog dass ich mit
SPR sie seid s keineklärt im Zug es
stimmt habe mit im Zug sie seid s so
hoch interessant gprch will ich gerade
Schauspiel n der Weise und das noch eine
sofessel der
weisech so
gute also sie GH es gibt eine
hochgeistige Version mit n an der Weise
da die Frau und es geht
mE menschliche die Frau als schöne
Frau nach im Z Glück ja ja Glüch hab
manknt also ich hat schon noch m kämpfen
bis ich meine Frau
kampflos
vorbegangen der mag ich mich erinnen
inür mit Sportwagen und ich mit de
militärvelo das ist das sind die
verschiedene Waffen gesehen aber ich hab
no
kun
[Musik]
also mir ja damals
daslich hat studiert
Student stell fertige
Ausbild immer
se
oder meine Frau ist
Primarlehrer und sie
hatfütine Frau geschaff
und mit dem Lohn h Sie mirbracht also
mir das nicht ganz furchtbar konkret
vorgestellt wie das mal los D ich sicher
nicht denkt dass er ein Unternehmer
werde ursprünglich hat eigentlich immer
denkt würde Richter werde wfangen mit
dem Studium ne das hät ich schon alles
gar nicht
[Musik]
denkt
es kommt anders und zwar wegen der
mschemie die zweite große Liebe
MS Chemie der größte private Arbeitgeber
des Kantons
[Musik]
Graubünden heute führt seine Tochter
Magdalena das
[Musik]
[Applaus]
unternehmenmen
[Musik]
die emserwerke Werner Oswald gründet das
Chemiewerk im Jahr
1936 für den industriearmen Kanton ist
das Großunternehmen zentral in den 50er
Jahren lanciert Oswald Nylon Kunstfasern
grillon
[Musik]
genannt das ist die einzige
vollsynthetische Faser die vollständig
in der Schweiz hergestellt wird in
diesem Augenblick wird ein Schaufenster
in zürrich mit sauberhaften
grillongeweben
[Musik]
geschmückt in dieser Zeit besucht der
Junge Gymnasiast Blocher das Unternehmen
wo ich im zweit bildingsweg sch gemacht
hab für Maturität der Minerva s mir in
der Chemie Stund auf Doms und da
empfangen interessant wie der oberste
Chef von dem Unternehmen der DR W
roswald und dann hat der schb der
chemihrer verzählt h gesag was ist
eiglich das SE der die Frage gestellt zu
der rohstoffemie da der was da für eine
d h der verzählt ja der Macht zwei
bildingsweg mittellos Student W in Wald
Zürich mit den älter und dann mir der do
wer roswald
ab Zimmer ihm der Familie in horge
damitmer und
mir sind jünger als ich oder und es wä
gut wenn Sie den auch noch der hausgaben
und so weiter und dann bin ich
Universität Kontakt verloren mit
da er rutschen jetzt in die Krise
grillon Textilfasern sind kein
Verkaufsschlager
mehr und bevor Doktor bevor ich anfangen
mit der Doktorarbeit ich ja wieder auf
mich zu mol WTE ger wieder mal mit mir
reden und Gag l sie sie Kön doch
halbtags zu mir auf
s das Unternehmen in
Rechtsdienst und sie halbtags
Dissertation schrieben das ke hernis B
ders und B den relativ kurzer Z Sekretär
worden B der Generalsekretär und dann
bin ich hblieben er hat natürlich ein
vertrauensm will will müss abgehen und
ich habe gemerkt der kann nicht recht
abgehen Unternehmen aufbaut und das ist
die Kraft bringt
nicht ich muss
blcher beginnt das Unternehmen umzubauen
er merkt rasch das basierend auf der
Grill und Technologie neue Produkte
möglich sind ich hab
cheid zum Teil wo ich gar nicht
kompetenk Produktionen abgestellt will
ich gemerkt der Chef da ob der im Fach
ein
B wirklich fü für das Unternehmen aber
zum dir schlechte Sachen abstellen zum
zneu die neuen Produkte von Blocher
lanciert haben
Erfolg in der Zeit der Umstellung stirbt
Werner Oswald
Oswalds Kinder beschließen das
Unternehmen zu
verkaufen am
Untergang se K die
fir amerikanische auf Elektrik und mit
rech gesag W auf Straß und ich gesagt
das nicht frag die bringen mir über der
Hufe wahcheinlich unvernünftig Blocher
inzwischen Vater von vier Kindern
entscheidet sich das Unternehmen zu
kaufen das ist große Diskussion s
natürlich die Meer Frau mit sie
natürlich seit l mal wen sch Gott glaube
ich noch dass du Familie kan überund
bringen aber wenn du stirbst und wenn
dir passiert hat ich vi
h 20 Millionen Schulder Firma mit
Verlust und
dann Risiko und ich muss träen ja ja du
h nicht trägen ich muss es trägen ein
lang dritt nach dir für uns stand im
Vordergrund das wenn schon ein Verkauf
in Frage kommt die Zukunft des
Unternehmens sicherzustellen ist was ein
Ausländer damit gemacht hätte können wir
nicht beurteilen ich darf Ihnen sagen
dass die Bankgesellschaft
ein gewichtiger derge wichtigste
Geldgeber dabei ist
alle anderen finanziellen Verhältnisse
sowie die Bedingungen dieser Kredite
darüber werden wir keine Auskunft
erteilen ich bitte Sie um das
entsprechende Verständnis
der Börsenwert des Unternehmens laut
Blocher damals 125 Millionen Franken
heute weiß man die Bankgesellschaft
gewährt ihm einen 20 Millionen Kredit er
muss als Sicherheit sein damaliges
Einfamilienhaus
hinterlegen Blocher sagt er habe mit dem
Kredit 17% des Aktienkapitals gekauft
sogenannte
Stimmrechtsaktien und so habe er über
die Stimmenmehrheit
verfügt ein gutes Geschäft aus heutiger
Sicht jetzt geht aber zung
s umgestellt und schon gewusst das kommt
gut und nacher die Firma günstig kauft
ja gut also das geht Hufer Theorie ich
hab zu dem pris kauft Elektriker kauft
hätte V Verkäufer und verkäuferinit
mindestens wich PR der nicht zahlt und
für mich ist das so viel Geld g und für
der pris h ni zu Kauf der schwitz aber W
kauft Frau Gesit also vor wir re
Weg es wird der S wenn sch got der groß
KZ ke ohne Geld so eine Firma kaufen und
alles in Abgrund
führenn
den neliss und ich mus sen ich hoffe es
R zwei Vorwurf
der in diesen Jahren beginnt auch
Blochers politische Blitzkarriere zuerst
Gemeindepolitiker dann Eintritt in die
SVP kurz darauf schon Zürcher
Parteipräsident und zi Jahre später
bereits
Nationalrat die freie Wahl zwischen
militärenst und zivilem Ersatzdienst ist
für unsere Armee
unzumutbar und mein Gewissen kann das
gegenüber der Verteidigung unseres
Landes nicht verantworten Herr Blocher
was machen sie nach dem 26 November mit
den Leuten die dieser Initiative
zugestimmt haben sollen die Winder DDR
ausgeschafft werden oder werden die als
Schweizerinnen und Schweizer wie bisher
anerkannt ich glaube darüber müssten wir
uns mal unterhalten
Helmut Hubacher in dieser Zeit Präsident
der Sozialdemokratischen Partei SP er
ist damals Blochers größter politischer
Gegner und der einzige Prominente SP
Politiker der mit SF über Blocher
sprach der BL Präsident von der stärkste
Kantonalpartei und sort geseh Dache
strateg
amterb jah stür meh über die
bundesfinanz nicht anders sag Spar und
immer ausgenommen die
militärosition
das
bürgerlichner
Ste
libling
das wier Fisch Wasserbruch Brauch der
politische Kampf das ist sie Element
von spannen mit dem zweit was denn
dasus nicht W die SVP ist damals in den
70er Jahren die kleinste
bundesratspartei sie verliert laufend
Sitze sie ist in der Krise Christop
Blocher beginnt die Partei umzubauen ich
Partei wir m auf ne grundlag stellen sie
ist ein bürgerliche
ibruchie und g h die Linke ste aber auf
noch links das bringt jetzt gar nicht
wir sind doch nicht glaubwürdig wenn wir
noch links auf wenn bur veruck machen
oder wenn die ganz Basis Bau Gewerbe
bürgerparteiere Partei
ursprünglichien oder und mir langbruch
bis wir die Linie gesamtchwizis
durgesetzt h und sie eigich nur
durgesetzt worden will mir Zürcher auf
Wahlerfolge könne vorwiese der
Schwangerschaftsabbruch darf nicht
grundsätzlich legalisiert werden wer
eine Schwangerschaft abbricht
vollstreckt ein Todesurteil dass der
Experte gefällt hat besonders mit dem
neuen Eherecht ist bei der Scheidung die
Existenz des Familienbetriebes stark
gefährdet dieses Gesetz
zahlreiche Ungerechtigkeiten und ich
sage es nochmals die schweizerische
Familie hat ein besseres ehrecht
verdient mit der Revision von
mecht sehr konservative alle die
verbesserige was für Frauen drin der
bekäft die weiß noch der schon nicht von
der Fremde Richter aber vor der Richter
imbett PL also stfall verloren
der ist worden und glaub der hätte sich
geschworen das soll nie mehr
[Musik]
passieren anfangs der 90er Jahre der
Bundesrat verhandelt mit der EU über den
Europäischen Wirtschaftsraum kurz EWR
genannt das Bundeshaus hat schon viele
Kundgebungen gesehen eine solche wie
heute aber noch nie 20 Spitzenmanager
gingen für den e auf die Straße der
Konzernchef als Demonstrant die Chefs
von ABB askum und Volksbank werden um e
[Applaus]
stimmen
ja tönt es aus der romie
zum in der ländlichen deutsschweiz
hingegen ist der Beitritt heftig
umstritten blind
blind
s nicht die Insel der Seligen zwischen
narwig und Rom und men wir könen da
funktionieren ohne dass wir irgendwie
mit dem Usland
schaffen der Bundesrat hat klare
Vorstellungen wie er mit Europa
zusammenarbeiten will er formuliert für
die Verhandlungen über den ewvertrag
konkrete
[Musik]
Mindestbedingungen genannt
verhandlungsrichtlinien des
desrates die wichtigste
mindestbedingung der Bundesrat fordert
ein sogenanntes opting out ein Vetorecht
gegen Gesetze die die Schweiz nicht
übernehmen
will deshalb ist Christoph Blocher
anfangs
einverstanden mir wäre das nicht gegenen
bitritt zum europäische wirtschaftsrum
sofern eine volle Mitbestimmung und
ähm es W rechtis g Regel müber sind
dasöllig die Verhandlungen leitet
Staatssekretär Franz blankard er soll
das opting out das vetorrecht
durchsetzen wenn wir eine Lösung die
beide Seiten
befriedigtarbeiten können dann ist es
gut und wenn es sicher weißt dass das
nicht möglich ist dann lassen wir
bleiben da wird die Schweiz nicht
unteren
und W zugegangen ist die nicht nur D der
Herr Staatssekretär blankard od der B h
wir das geschildert wir habenürlich dass
das zugegangen
ist die beiden Bundesräte fellber und
damyra fliegen nach Brüssel zu
[Musik]
schlussverhandlungen Staatssekretär
Franz blank inzwischen verstorben hat
Jahre der den Ablauf des Treffens in
einer Notiz
festgehalten damals gewus dass es so
eine Set Treff geht ich habe vom Treffen
gewusst ich hab auch gewusst das
schlusstreffen ist wir aber nicht gewüst
ob Schwiz das wet recht dur bringt
streng vertraulich heißt es im Dokument
welches inzwischen im Bundesarchiv frei
zugänglich ist signiert von den
Bundesräten und düllmü eigentlich haben
beide Bundesräte laut Geheimpapier den
klaren Auftrag das opting out das
vetorrecht durchzusetzen selbst Zitat
auf die Gefahr eines Scheiterns der
Verhandlungen
[Musik]
Hines
nachass und reichlich gegessen und
reichlich getrunken ü dass der dam und
der Felber gern trinken also nicht nur
Wasser es sind nur
ministerwesend
alle ander münus blieben also
tolmetcher Mitarbeiter
Staatssekretäre unter anderem der
wichtigste Staatssekretär der Sach von
Schwiz der
Blankart und der D und der sag los sie
mir W den Übersetzer
be fast in Siegerpose verließ Bundesrat
um 2 Uhr in der Früh das egzentrum in
Brüssel die Verhandlungen um ein EW
waren nicht abgebrochen worden und die
Schweiz war noch mit dabei und wo die
sind gar nicht D das wet rechfall
willgesam haben die schweizerminister
meh
in Brüssel als
geplant heute wissen wir an diesem Essen
wird das optingout das vetorcht die
Mindestbedingungen der Schweiz
gestrichen die zwei Bundesräte haben die
rote Linie
überschritten es regt sich Widerstand in
der Regierung bundesratiger schreibt in
einem vertraulichen Bericht an seine
Kollegen agen deshalb dass die
Verhandlungen abgebrochen
werden die Bundesratsmehrheit wählt
einen anderen Weg ein EU Beitrittsgesuch
dann könne die Schweiz wenigstens
mitgestalten heißt
es ich wün Ihnen einen guten Morgen
einen morgen der sich über ein völlig
neuen
europahe diese neue Dynamik eines EW
diese Öffnung diese sinnvolle
Veränderung durchlüftet auch unseren
Geist und unsere
Institutionen schließlich um 4 Uhr früh
ließ Bundesrat RNE Felber noch eine
mittlere politbombe
Platzen der Bundesrat hat inzwischen
entschieden diesen EW nur noch als
Etappe anzusehen als Etappe mit dem
Ziel einer vollständigen Integration der
Schweiz in der EG
also und ich h seit wenigens klar was W
sie w die und der RE ist der Vorhof das
ist eine von der größte fleisen vom
bundesrag wenn man der EU B dann ist das
nur eintimmig 7 Null das ist 4 d
strategisch taktisch g das
totale
dassitunkt mit Nummer zu drei W ne bit Z
machen und dann hab wir gesagt mir
bekämpfen das es nicht einfach ist das
ist klar das bra Kraft braucht Vitalität
D B ich praktisch je die Woche zwei dre
mal da mus da mus
volollk g
Politiker gen verlobig ich s jedes Mal
ich habe noch nie gesehen meine Damen
und Herren dass ich ein verlobt hat mit
der festen Absicht nicht
z W grüß Wirtschaft ist dafür alle
Parteien sind dafür Medien sind dafür
Fernseh ist dafür Radio ist dafür alles
ist dafür will mir nicht dur die der
MF jetzt machen mir jeden Daag
mindestens ein
Vortrag wir W J
Einzel immer nur gegil sch
Gegenteil ein
G das ist was sie machen hören Sie doch
auf da der Kampf V David gegen der
Goliat nicht g aber
das das Schle h ja
s Schwiz wieder W Welt wieder ich bin
total kein Politikerin
überhaupt nicht und interessiert mir
nicht aber also was er SEAG das finde
ich einfach Hand und Fu ich finde ih ein
Politiker der noch ehrlich ist den man
noch glauben kann in Bern und nicht wie
die anderen sieben Vögel eigentlich in
das gleiche Horn blasen der
ist der Schweiz der Churchill in der
[Musik]
Schweiz Position
bitim träumt ich stand unter Berghang wo
ein Bergsturz auf mich zT und ich mus
ganz le
der der
Bergsturz immer wieder ich
das Bergsturz und ich hat
B schwach und den nach Schweiß gebad
verwachet
und natürlich D
denkt Recht oder überbordisch oder od
verrennt KT alles se aber am Morgen wenn
z Aufgang ich wieder
gewüst das Mus ma falsch es ist eine der
emalsten
der Bundesrat l sie deshalb liebe
mitbürgerinen und Mitbürger einstimmig
und mit voller Überzeugung ein dem EW
zuzustimmen die Schweiz hat sich am
Wochenende für den Alleingang in Europa
entschieden volk und Stände haben das
Abkommen über den europäischen
wirtschaftsraumw abgelehn dasürfte die
am
knappstenescheerte Vorlage der
Nachkriegszeit sein erstaunlich bei
dieser Abstimmung auch die sehr sehr
hohe Stimmbeteiligung
78,3% das hat es seit
1947 nie mehr
gegeben es ist für mich eine free Volk
die Kraft aufgebracht hat zu diesem
Entscheid gegen das ganze politische und
wirtschaftliche Establishment dieses
Landes wenn wir der verloren hätt wäen
wir der Europäische Union da bin ich
überzeugt
her damit hätte
natürlich politische große bed über mit
dem Sieg einer gegen alle kann man sagen
und abstimm
ich ja
also nervenze Bruch und noch ich mich D
Wochen zurückzogen in die völlige
Einsamkeit in das jagdus im im
vorallbergische wo wir dörf hinter fahre
und F ist es zwei Stund zum nächste Dorf
also be ganze
Leid Frau
N kochen g LAF und jeden Tag von morgen
am 8 bis zauig bin ich gelaufen bin auch
föllig völlig
[Musik]
gesundet ich politisiere so wenn ich für
gut finde ich bin der Präsident von der
zür SVP der größte Partei im Kanton
Zürich und mir Po
so es richtig ist natürlich nicht dass
wir kleinere Partei werden sonder eine
größere al ist freisinige Partei und CVP
für
EU und der Blocher den der Flügel rech
die Flügel von der CVP und der rechte
Flügel von der FDP sie großer Teil zu
SVP überg der bler den kassiert VB der
konservative Flügel vor beide
bürgerliche Partei FDP und CVP übern und
ist das vor der klinste zur stärchste
bundesratspartei
worden wir sind erstens anders als die
anderen und zweitens besser als die
anderen und das wollen wir auch sein
darum haben wir auch
überdurchschnittliche Erträge
Generalversammlung der
memschemie Nationalrat Christoph Blocher
ist auch ein listiger
Unternehmer da Ems dank des guten
Geschäftsabschlusses über hohe liquide
Mittel verfügt schlägt ihnen der
Verwaltungsrat vor dieses Jahr das
nominelle Aktienkapital von 62 Millionen
auf 31 Millionen Franken zu reduzieren
das was sie bekommen hier diese 50
Franken pro Aktie das ist für sie kein
Kapitalgewinn und das ist für sie auch
keine auch auch kein Einkommen und das
müssen Sie nicht
versteuern wir müssen jedes Jahr einen
neuen Weg suchen immer wenn wir etwas
Interessantes haben dann versucht man es
in Bern wieder zu
durchkreuzen wir können es in der Regel
einmal durchführen weil wir immer einen
Schritt voraus
sind aber ein zweites Mal geht es
meistens nicht
mehr für Blocher bedeutet das damals 7
Millionen Franken steuerfreie
[Musik]
[Applaus]
Wertsteigerung jetzt als Patriot wo sie
sind müsst sie nicht eigentlich len dass
der Staat Z gute stü
kommt mal sagen ein
patriotfür
sger Land viel stür mus
zilat wenig stü zah will nmlich der
Einzel geh Staat das ist viel besser für
Volkswirtschaft wenn der Staat alles
[Musik]
ABS die Bilanz
mitwi ST wir fest dass immer mehr von
den praktisch wenig bis ke zahen und
wenn in der Schwiz h ist das die Tatsach
dass die war hfe h und hfe verd immer
weniger Stiere zahlen und das eigentlich
die dummen dem Land sind
die ich bin Unternehmer ich bin
Unternehmer ich persönlich ich verstüre
keimnis von Million
viel ich ver möge das alles unternehmen
wir mit Milliarde geschätzt ich zahle
pro Jahr persönlich stüre 6,7 Millionen
Franken ich muss m jedes Jahr mit 6
Millionen Franken Verschulden das kann
ich wenn der Wert vom Unternehmen
zunimmt so jetzt leg Sachen auf der
Tisch wenn sie sagen die Z ich ma da
nicht mitig allgemeinen W den sie h Geld
geh V ihrem Vater wenn nicht so viel geh
schon lange großes Unternehmen gemacht
zeig sie mir mal W den das Bienen
jetzt ich V 1 ich bin Dimension
das ich zahle let J in zammenhang mit
dem Projekt wir machen mehrere 100
Franken wir zaht rein Stempel und
Grundstück s nicht und von Gefühl und
Vermögen Vermögen das Schenk ver me
Vater ist vor kurzem gestorben und das
schon nicht nicht
versten das GT
im wenig
ST ich Kisch mit bisch selber
Z wenn milliard wenn milliard Verm h
wie Unternehmen wenn milliard vermge in
der schwitz zwei Problem erstens mal das
wir ke
Kapital für sich ein milliard vermge h
keine schaffe aber nur Million verstiert
das heißt das ist das
Promill im D und ihr s eigentliches
beispielfür we ich würde sagen es war
wichtig es war wichtig dass wir probier
die in der Schwiz kapitalgewintier in
Fähre damit so vermge W ihr h dass die
nicht unterm Radar
durchchmen danke für die erhell auskft
über persönliche verhältn
[Musik]
Hand
Schulter das mit dem machen wir GFT
Schweizer
Qualität
auf dieser Stelle möchte ich
insbesondere Nationalrat Herr Dr
brer herzlich dafür danken dass ihr seit
langem unermütliche Anstrengungen zur
Entwicklung freundschaftliche Beziehung
zwischen China und der Schweiz
unternimmt wenn wir in China bauen sie
haben viele Menschen nicht was die
suchen Arbeit
soll auch sehr big ja günstiger als
ihr aber aber Sie müssen sehen dort
müssten wir nicht so moderne Anlagen
bauen wir bauen Ihnen trotzdem die
modernsten ich hab KZ let
mal Sie sie mit chinesische Kommunisten
vielständiger als mit Sozialdemokrat in
der Schwiz seit stimmt stimmt hat gesagt
aber ST mir n ist sie
sieus das Schloss rzüns heute im Besitz
der
[Musik]
emschemie von 1809 bis 1814 gehört es
Napoleon napoleon hat es persönlich
gekauft so geht
mitinand so danke schön das glaubt man
dass das der Stuhl von Napoleon gewesen
sei
das sagt man
[Musik]
jaitte bitte bitte bitte
aber so se Bild
nicht absolu Widerspruch das aus
Kommunist mit dem
kommunistischenaff istchafft das das
kommt ganz Z das nehmen BL gar nicht ich
ne höchstenel dass er der schwitz das
schel behandelt wenn er mit der chines
Kommunisten so gut geschaffet sag
Sozialismus ist verwerf falsche
Ideologie auf s ein von den Erie wo mit
Sozialist also mit dem kommunistische
China geschäftet mit derschemie ist das
nicht wierspruch
nein für mich sind auch politische
Gegner die pfind als
Menschen ich bin klar gegen
Sozialismus Sozialismus viel zerstört
auf der Welt W der
Nationalsozialist Nationalsozialismus
auch der darum s dr Sozialismus S und da
blieb ich völlig verwerfliche Ideologie
der
Nationalsozialismus heute wissen wir die
mschemie setzte nach Kriegsende auf
nationalsozialistische
Chemiker doch kein Wort über das dunkle
Kapitel in der Unternehmensgeschichte
der mschemie
Werner Oswald engagierte damals die
nazichemiker sie halfen ihm nach dem
Zweiten Weltkrieg neue Produkte zu
entwickeln grillon Kunstfasern eine
nylonähnliche Phase ursprünglich
erfunden im nationalsozialistischen
Deutschland der wichtigste deutsche
Chemiker Johann gesen während der
Nazizeit war er Direktor des
methanolwerks Auschwitz Monowitz
tausende von Zwangsarbeitern
dort gesen wird nach Kriegsende
Verwaltungsrat der
emserwerke damals ist Blocher noch nicht
bei der MS doch das Buch das die dunkle
Vergangenheit ausblendet hat er
[Musik]
mitverantwortet also falsch dargestellt
hätich wieess und wenn sie so
Geschichte sind
das so Sache wo ja wo wir später
wiralisiert und SEAG noch komisch s
glaub no saib aber wegen dem dem W sie
mir sind natürlich gewünt der Industrie
wir schaffen da mit L wo Sünder
[Musik]
sind her und Fr Bundesrat seit vi Jahren
sitzt Christop Blocher jetzt in der
Landesregierung sein politstil
provoziert für die konkordanzregierung
eine
dauerbelastungile
bundesr will
MW Gefängnis SP bundesus und noch einit
ja istch also weiß von me freisindig KF
wit die hat Blocher im Bundesrat gewählt
damitespert im Gefängnis und immer da
frei politisiert in der
Bevölkerung und jetzt ist halb jah und
derängndektor die wierwahl steht
an sich die Kritik Blocher sei
ungeeignet für ein Kollegium und vor
allem er habe seine Macht missbraucht
einen banquier vor einer
justizuntersuchung geschützt
komplottvorwürfe werden
laut
dann der
Verdacht löst sich in Luft
auf was wir in den letzten Wochen erlebt
haben war der konzertierte Versuch
Bundesrat Christop Locher aus dem Amt zu
entfernen das sind so
riff wir hab BL
zumt das ist ja es ist
einfach einfach primitiv oder die SVP
schlägt zurück mit einer Kampagne
Geheimplan gegen
Blocher alle die nicht für Christop
Blocher sind sollen plötzlich Teil eines
geheimkomplott sein meine Herren der SVP
verschonen Sie uns doch vor diesem
parteipolitischen Peinlichkeiten die SVP
vergiftet die Schweizer
Politik ein Klima des Hasses und der
Intoleranz werden geschürt unser Auftrag
ist es den politischen Sonderfall
Schweiz unser erfolgmodell gegen die
Banalisierung gegen die Personifizierung
gegen die Polarisierung zu verteidigen
ich glaube treffender könnte unsere
wahlaussage nicht sein SVP wählen
Blocher stärk
es folgt eine millionenschwere
Wahlkampagne der
SVP und sie gewinnt die Parlamentswahlen
2007 klar in diese Zeit fällt auch ein
umstrittener Fernsehauftritt von
Christoph Blochers Bruder Gerhard er
muss der ganze
saulade vor äßer schwezerische
Politik und du Christof
einzig
und wenn wir da al merkt man gerade was
bedeutet das heißt nchkampf und das
heißt
Blut
dasahpenal wenn mit Z Ding ja
das wenn ich wegt wde dann geht
riesen herzlich willkommen in der Arena
zu der Bundesratswahl ist der Herr
Bundesrat schon so gut wiet wieder ich
bin überzt bundesr Blocher wird gewäht
und vor allem ist es wichtig dass er
wieder gewählt wird die einzige von ihr
sus Chance der bundeser abzwäh wä D sie
sich auf über akzeptierte linksliberaler
wahrscheinlich CVP Kandidat würde
einigen oder das ist absolut wichtig und
Kandidatur CP Wenn son Kandidatur für
selbverständlich D D wir über die we
diskutieren doch heimlich hat die SP
bereits die sprengkandidatur mit Eveline
witm Schlumpf
[Musik]
eingefädelt evelyine witm Schlumpf eine
Bündner SVP Regierungsrätin in Bern kaum
bekannt ohne Sitz im
Nationalrat also bisher wurden die
diversesten Namen genannt ich weiß nicht
ob ich die jetzt alle wiederholen
soll Madam Schlumpf ist ein Name her
Bloch lang danke
lang
was viele im ratsal nicht wissen evely
witm Schlumpf ist zu dieser Zeit bereits
unterwegs im Zug nach
Bern gewählt ist mit 125 Stimmen Madame
[Applaus]
schlum
ihre Rolle bei Blochers Abwahl ist bis
heute
umstritten und natürlich alles sch S auf
fah auf Bären bevor be wah stark
Fund in diesem Sinne erkläre ich Annahme
der
[Musik]
Wahl
hervorragen das ist super Sach ich bin
total überrascht dass es ger
ist schlumze
Bundes das
kann total
überrascht total viit aber
[Applaus]
[Musik]
ziemlich das persönlich sicher schon
troffen ja selbverständlich also also
wenn das trifft ich
trotteltlichertig
Parlamente können zwar Leute aus der
Regierung entfernen aber nicht aus der
Politik und nicht aus dem politischen
schaffen im
Lande und S natürlich mit dem muss
wählen denkt jetzt ist SVP
erledigt mit dem wenn maner ist SVP
geschwcht und nacher W SVP noch stärker
worden ist vi
Jahr n damit es den wirklich gchwächt
ist aber das ist nicht
aufgegangen in seinem Wohnort herleberg
empfangen begeisterte Anhänger den
abgewählten
[Musik]
Bundesrat
sehr
dankbar
was
wast we aber es zeig für W
[Musik]
gchaff ich natürlich auch Vorteil W seeh
ich will
Unternehmer le lang ich hat z die
Unternehmen geh die diet ich
zurückziehen noch zi jah geshen dass es
gut könnt und die Unternehmen sind h g h
also da mus ich sagen ich hab den wieder
nach dem Bundesrat Selb unternehme
gründet aber die ursprüngliche
unternehme die führt min und
Gehör Werk halt auf
Verlangen seit 2004 führt Tochter
Magdalena matul Blocher die
mschemies
beim Erwerb durch Christ bler einen
Börsenwert von 125 Millionen Franken
hatte ist heute mehrere Milliarden wert
Tochter matulo führt so selbstbewusst
wie ihr
Vater
manementining
stepsing
steps ze oder
was
US
schlaask
pleas
ja Mr Kel nein Mr
kppelting
[Musik]
dreonders Posi entwickel sich die
Geschäfte in
as
[Musik]
Christop Blocher ist inzwischen als
Nationalrat zurückgetreten jetzt
kandidiert seine Tochter als Zürcherin
im Kanton
Graubünden was ist
[Musik]
los was ist
losem super
schemacht aber wie machen wir das
herzliche Gratulation super
super jetzt
los eine schöne
Überraschung wir haben
gekämpft
H
er Blocher Gott also wier ich sch
zumanla galgani wo jetzt die frisch
gewählt die nationalrötin im Interview
hat man hat mich natürlich im Kanton
schon kannt das größte Unternehmerin und
ich bin sehr engagiert im wahlkampfgang
ich bin überall unterwegs g ich bin B l
man hat mich
[Applaus]
Ken stärker als
C
wie können Sie die beide Mandate machen
also Ihre Firma und jetzt Bern habe mich
natürlich vorbereitet für diesem Fall
schon bei meiner Kandidatur ich bleibe
aber in meiner Funktion
selbstverständlich mein Vater hat das 30
Jahre lang gemacht das
geht zurück zum pensionierten
[Musik]
Bundesrat 13 Jahre lang verzichtete er
auf seine
bundesratsrente dann im Jahr 2020 will
er sie
[Musik]
doch das ja ich machen W ich n
gemeinüzig sa ich
gemacht Bund ich
denke
dieah
sche erhäl 1,1 Millionen 5 Jahre statt
Jahre
fertig B
wohltätig Bund
aber
oder iche kein
Geld
un g aber wenn sie knug vermöge
h Geld mus
sorgen
bundesratsrentek jetzt monatlich im
Moment dann jetzt nicht im Kopf also die
normale renteüber das ist 80% also im
Jahr sind das ungefähr 200 2000 Franken
glaube ich als im JR und der Teil von
dem Geld Fließ
sicher
politische Arbeit Gott auch generell
Partei hat ich nie unterstützt ne
sondern nur für Aktionen
wiekampf sehr viel oder oder andere
abstimm wo ich finde die sind wichtig
fürs Land nicht da kulfe ja ja wie viel
FLI daine ja da weiß ja nicht W ja nicht
wssen wenn wü wenn ich es noch Wüste
würde es nicht zeen warum nicht ja we
sie wissen ja warum das das ist wen sie
argumentieren warum ich für das Geld geh
und für das nicht D sind sie dem zü nein
das das frag dann
jemand ja
ja abstellen oder
was was ist
da trinken
sichine Frau was se sie
da
Sicherheitsgurte danst gut
also Christoph Blocher gibt nach der
Abwahl zwar nach und nach alle
Funktionen ab politisch aber bleibt er
aktiv
[Applaus]
Aufmarsch in der
Innerschweiz Christoph Blocher und seine
Entourage
feiern nach 7 Jahren bricht der
Bundesrat die Verhandlungen mit der EU
ab das Rahmenabkommen ist gescheitert
wie es weitergeht ist unklar die
Schweizer Europapolitik ist blockiert
[Applaus]
[Musik]
K mit
handellt das
Mikrofon super warum sind wir eigentlich
warum versammel wir e da es ist doch
dass der bundesort am 26 Mai
einentscheid TR W Unabhängigkeit und
selbstbestimmig Land verteidig
wer dass das
rmenabkommen W nie
passiert
SVP das ichaubt dass das sch auf der
Stufe
bundesr dass die über den schat springen
das ist ganz großer lblick dass das der
bundesratferbcht ich habe mich auf
volksabstimm vorbereitet und
stimmig machen
aber nicht allzu groß den gegenf wi die
H nicht fanatisch wenn h jetzt alles
machen um die Schwiz bringen mir
Freiheitsrecht selber
bewachen
siestind
verteig
und
ich V mit Wikinger ich ihr ber ihr v
[Applaus]
[Musik]
büm Jahr 2021 g bewus einfach
parteimitgliederordert Gebäude
stürmen
nicht
nicht Büro mit dem Sturm das ist nicht
so quasi vor
B sie
machen sch das Z Bundeshaus
undür verboten ist und lupf dir zum
Sessel los das ist also alles dumszug er
einfach Gag Tri mal die geisterus da das
und das gemacht ich weiß immer genennt
was geschlossenen abteiligen im
Bundeshaus die Gefühl sie bess die
habfüh sie sich F abstreifen am Land und
ich glaub S
der und Schwiz schwizis also
[Musik]
dieich Männer und Frauen der Freiheit
zur Sammlung mir Manet passet auf hütet
euch zwar nicht an ggarten aber hütet
euch vor den ewigen Schweiz Gegnern die
uns in die EU führen also der Kampf geht
wi ja
eidütiger es lebe die Schweiz
Gott
[Musik]
[Applaus]
meen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
es
[Musik]